mais organiser en urgence à l'elysée
après des semaines d'un bras de fer
entre paris et la junte malienne qui a
remis en question le futur de
l'opération barkan le statu quo n'était
pas possible dans un contexte très
dégradé au mali avec la prise de pouvoir
par une jante le refus d'appliquer un
calendrier de retour à l'ordre
démocratique qui avait pourtant été
annoncée et le recours à une milice
privée russe ce n'est pas un sujet
franco-malien vous le savez emmanuel
macron reçoit mercredi soir les
présidents du niger du tchad et de la
mauritanie membres du g5 celle à la
veille du sommet entre l'union
européenne et l'union africaine le
président du conseil européen charles
michel et le chef de la diplomatie de
l'union josep borrell seront également
présents depuis plusieurs semaines
bamako accusent paris de diviser le pays
sur fond de manifestations contre
l'ingérence française la junte au
pouvoir a expulsé fin janvier
l'ambassadeur de france au mali elle a
également demandé au danemark de
rapatrier la centaine d'hommes envoyés
dans le cadre du groupement européen
takouba initiants 2020 par la france
pour partager le fardeau sécuritaire
bamako dénoncé un déploiement intervenue
sans son consentement des actes de
souveraineté qui ont fragilisé la
coalition internationale à l'image de la
suède qui a annoncé son retrait du pays
paris espère néanmoins convaincre ses
alliés de ne pas se désengager
totalement de la sécurité au sahel mais
aussi dans le golfe de guinée
directement menacé par l'insurrection
islamiste